no i know a couple of
maybe
but yeah because social media like
everybody can have so much access to
what's going on in your life if you post
enough so they don't actually need to
physically stalk you mm-hmm do you want
do you know what i mean yeah um i don't
know i should ask saying to you have you
ever dated a fan before
an experience with oh that's a that's a
something that wasn't a no
no because i interviewed people too
um i've gone on a date with the fan but
there was no second date sorry why what
happened
nothing really to be honest it wasn't
like it was just i don't know like it
was fine and then you just don't go
honest you know
but
yeah have you ever been stalked
no
you've never been stalked no i don't
think so you're being stalked right now
you just don't know it someone's
probably talking about it i get nervous
sometimes
i get scared sometimes
like it's just i have had someone
threatened to come beat me up in my
apartment i'm more scared of women to be
honest than men
oh really why is that because they're
crazy
because a man knows if he hits me like
there's consequences or like a woman
like they just get away with everything
so
like yeah this girl was like threatening
to come to my apartment and beat me up
with her
yeah i don't know she was
um
i don't know so
what's um
your friend jess who if anybody watches
post channel you would see
she used to have uh
what you would call kind of the modern
woman's mindset in regards to dating in
men right and then you kind of red
pilled her so she wasn't too bad oh she
was already kind of on the wavelength or
um i mean i think everyone's every
girl's kind of modern to some extent
mm-hmm like you don't really have like
of course yeah yeah um but i mean she's
really open-minded
but she like there's some girls that are
like super
too far gone but she was kind of in the
middle she didn't but then
you just show her stuff and she's like
oh i see what you're saying
but yeah go ahead no well i was just
going to say what was um
how how was her because she's a female
friend of yours and i know you said you
know you've kind of felt that some
female friends of yours might have
distanced themselves because of your
views yeah etc etc because they've said
that so like word for word they they
have said that yeah but there you go
yeah
i think that but she
obviously she's still a close friend and
maybe her opinions have shifted i want
to see how much have they shifted in
regards to
you know the things that you say about
women and men no no i would say she
no she looks at the world different too
because it's like once you see it you
cannot see it the world discriminates
against men
even even in our language like he
knocked her up why is it on him
yeah that's true
she got pregnant like you take it's even
even in our language like we take
accountability off of women well i
i hear that
but what i would say is um
is there no an element if you want a man
to be the leader then he does have to
take responsibility
for the people that he wants to lead
right would you say most women are
letting men lead
most women in relationships oh
i think so yeah because i think happy
relationships are quiet you don't hear
about them you only hear about the bad
ones and i think there's more happy ones
that people realize why are 50 percent
of women that hit 30 single and
childless
that say again where are 50 of women
that hit 30 single and childless if
women are letting men lead by and large
well no you're when you when you asked i
said within relationships
like i always ask women what would you
require for submission and i say to the
point like you know he tells you to quit
your job and you trust him he's figuring
it out
yeah so do you mean it's always and it's
always top like six figures top 10
percent guy and i say then my next
question are you top 10 women no so in
regards to earnings
no one regards to looks and like what
like where are you in the top 10 of
women competitively mm-hmm like in the
market you go you go take 100 women are
you in the top 10 when it comes to like
femininity looks like what
by and large we can kind of agree with
men like i hear that yes by and large
yeah the same way like you know there's
there's some nuance but are you in the
top 10 they'll say no
average guys can't get submission only
like
top 10 guys why do you think this would
you say this mindset is quite common
with your experience with talking to
women yeah why do you think that's why
you think that's really common amongst
women but men do you think men are
unrealistic as well or
no it's because you guys keep screwing
these fat chicks
oh he's an average girl it's okay
it's it's because
the hot guys gassed up the girl's ego so
they think they're like hotter than they
are did that not used to happen though
because because before
you had
brothers and dads to tell you oh honey
don't don't go there oh so you think
it's because they're not being told at
home no no it's partially because women
left who are we're horrible left to our
own devices
horrible no you're just repeating that
no i genuinely believe you're just
repeating that from myron gaines
no
no not myron um
no no i i believe that like matt you
know okay who do you think would pick a
better husband
in general a father yeah but who would
pick a better wife
a mother or a father
oh probably mother right yeah so what's
your point
like like all the things carry on no
actually
because all the things that i'll be
honest like all the things when it comes
to
women and watch look out for it's i get
that from my mom not my dad i'm saying
i'm not saying it doesn't go both ways
but i'm saying left to our own devices
and dating we don't do well it's better
to have men involved so do you believe
the same for men
left to their own advices
not always but i think
i think men are a little bit more
logical in general
by and large i think men
in general
make decisions based on logic more than
emotion i think women make decisions
on emotion more than logic the issue
with men is they have this innate like
protection thing towards women that's
right and i think women take advantage
of that
that's that's what i think and so i
don't necessarily think like a lot of
guys get into the situation they're in
because the girl kind of like traps them
to some level like how do you mean
outside of trapping them with a baby how
do you mean yeah that's what i mean a
baby or or like he's around long enough
where he kind of feels like he has to
get married is what i see
and
he doesn't have to do anything like if
he chooses to then then that's the
choice i agree but that's a different
mindset than a lot of guys
but then that's but then that's when the
guy not on the go you're you're right
but we're in a society that like caters
to women
and so i'm saying he's been told from a
young age to man up be more that's your
responsibility get married like he's
been told all these things that cater
women from like a young age yeah so it's
not as as quick as just turn that off
some some guys like you like you get it
you're like nah i ain't
like pipe down pipe down i don't say
that
all the time
you know what i'm saying like you get it
but a lot of guys like don't know their
value
because women have been telling them
they ain't [ __ ] from like a young age
but girls use that like innate
protection and their beauty to like
i think put up a smoke screen against a
lot of guys just like my friend and
actually i wouldn't i wouldn't call her
friend but like girl girl on my girl my
associate
an acquaintance yeah yeah in in college
right like she had a whole smoke screen
up
to get what she wanted
right and i think a lot of guys like